hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about a a question a subject
that comes up all the time people ask me
how long does it take to learn a
language
and i want to talk about this because of
what i am experiencing now in learning
arabic
so
uh you know as i struggle with arabic
and you know i i study the
letters i read you know with the help of
hearing the words and then i decipher
the letters that are there and i'm
getting better at it but it just seems
so frustrating when you start into a
language things that we think we have
learned we we forget we can't i see the
word again i know i've read the word
several times before and i still have
trouble reading the word i need to hear
it before i can actually with any
confidence read it
part of that of course is that we tend
to second guess ourselves and we're not
confident enough to just go for it i
think it's this word kind of thing
so i'm saying to myself you know i've
only been out of a week and already i'm
frustrated i'm impatient why why am i
not better and of course if i can't read
then i'll have trouble understanding
what i hear when i listen to it
so i want to get better at reading so
how long is this all going to take so
then i thought of all the other
languages that i have learned
and the things that influence how
quickly we can learn
before doing that it just so happened
that i discovered
this is a map of europe and it's called
foreign service institute this is the
u.s foreign service institute
language difficulty rankings it's not
just europe is europe middle east north
africa and it ranks these languages for
difficulty and i will put a link to the
description box but their estimates of
of the amount of time it takes
are based on intensive study and i'll
get into that but for intensive study
based on instance intensive study 24
weeks
24 weeks what's that that's
i guess five months and a bit
will get you languages in group one if
you're an english speaker that's the
scandinavian languages
that's french spanish portuguese italian
and so forth those are the closest and
easiest
i
group two which is now 30 weeks they've
added another month and a half
would be essentially german
then the next level of difficulty
according to them
is group three
which it doesn't even show up on this
map here uh group four is languages with
significant difficulty
and uh they are
uh oh and i should have they put
romanian in as a quickie 24 weeks so
group 4 is finnish russian the slavic
languages turkish and stuff like that
and that's 44 weeks so it almost doubles
the amount of time required
and the really more difficult languages
like arabic chinese and stuff like that
goes to 88 weeks like it's four times as
long as it takes to learn say swedish
french spanish so
that's what fsi says what has been my
experience well
i think it depends on two things it when
they say x number of weeks that's based
on intensive study that means probably
five hours a day with a teacher
uh so the things that impact it are
three things actually
how similar the language is to a
language you already know
the second thing is how much time you
spend how intensively you study and the
third thing is
um
what was the third thing again what you
want to achieve so what do you what do
you call if you're saying you know is it
fluency you want to achieve or what so
if i look at different languages so
arabic for example
and the reason i came to this was
because of my you know
present experience call it frustrations
depending on the day although i'm
starting to really enjoy the sound of
arabic and i enjoy the letters i'm
enjoying it i'm frustrated that i'm not
better
and i should say that i was very
impressed i managed to find a video of
ollie richards
producing uh egyptian arabic after three
months and i thought wow i'll never be
able to do that it's much like when i
saw judith meyer
speaking hebrew i think after six months
and i thought to myself wow i don't
think i can achieve that so part of it
of course is how
you know
what your goals uh your goals uh what
you want to achieve how much time you
put in and some people might be better
than others so maybe i'm not as good as
ollie richards or judith meyer
but let's take some languages chinese
essentially i was reading the newspaper
reading books
interpreting and stuff after nine to 12
months
but
i had i was at it six seven hours a day
which included three hours a day
one-on-one with a teacher that and i was
being paid as a canadian diplomat so
that was my job so
that was chinese
uh russian which i did on my own because
i'm not being paid to study right now i
study out of interest so i have an hour
an hour and a half i have other
activities sports family
business
friends so it's not a sort of obsessive
you know struggle like what chinese was
so the russian i was a year two years
still having trouble reading
understanding listening
uh speaking
so that was russian now after russian
several years of russian
i decided to do czech well after a year
of check even though the grammar is very
similar maybe
50 of the vocabulary is recognizable
uh
still when i went to prague to try to
activate it
i struggled now i didn't do a lot of
speaking i didn't do a lot of online
speaking i didn't have a one-on-one
teacher nothing i was just learning on
my own much as was the case with russian
although i had more conversations with
evgeny and helena and other russian
tutors at link
so that's even after a year i wasn't
where i would say that i was fluent in
czech despite having had russian but
after check then ukrainian and polish
were easier but still i was at ukrainian
for quite a long while and it took a
visit to levive
and uh
three weeks there with four or five
hours of uh ukrainian speaking every day
and i i would say that i'm a b2 in
ukrainian today
so there again that's a couple of hours
now if i had a tutor
uh three hours a day and another three
hours a day to spend of course
that time period would be shrunk
significantly
so relating the all of that back to
arabic
given that i have an hour and hour and a
half a day
i'm not yet at the stage where i can
just listen away from the computer
because i don't understand the thing i'm
listening to
i think i'll start to gain more traction
as i start to understand more then i'll
be able to activate my my listening in
the car and while exercising and doing
the dishes and stuff i think that my
familiarity with the letters can only
get better it's not going to get worse
so the frustration that forgetting and
not being able to read and stuff will
gradually gradually decline if i'm able
to read more fluently and understand
better when i listen i'll pick up speed
nevertheless at an hour an hour and a
half a day i think uh a couple of years
in arabic i have to be realistic
therefore
i have to enjoy it
enjoy the stuff i'm listening to
uh enjoy and that's why for example
we've now got the first ten stories and
we're having all of the many stories
redone because we had one to ten up at
link but um we only had one to ten and
we were waiting and waiting we didn't
get any more
and the sound quality wasn't ideal and
we now have had someone who's an
egyptian a lady but she reads in modern
standard arabic her voice is very
pleasant the sound is very clear
so
i i know i'm going to be able to enjoy
listening to these stories over and over
again so that's going to help
i
when i was in bratislava at the last
polyglot conference i bought an assy
meal book there because there was a very
persuasive and very friendly gentleman
philippe from asimil who persuaded me
that this was the best possible way to
you know learn arabic so i'm going to
definitely go through those books i
ordered another book because i like
books and i it's fun for me to cover
some of the same material by a different
sort of channels
so
as long as i can keep myself motivated
and enjoying it then it doesn't bother
me that arabic to achieve a decent level
is going to be
more than a year and depending on how
much time i spend per day it could be
two years that's how long it'll take now
let's contrast that with for example
romanian
uh
you know if i compare romanian to korea
i've spent far more time on korean than
romanian not even close but romanian was
extremely easy because 70 of the
vocabulary is similar to italian and the
structure is somewhat similar so that i
don't have to get my brain used to
things that i'm not from you know that
the brain is not used to like uh cases
in russian or verbs of motion or in any
of the slavic languages so that was a
that was
in fact very easy after a month i think
two months of studying on my own i went
to romania
i was able to speak to romanians uh talk
to people in bookstores
uh and uh i could understand a fair
amount of political podcasts i'm nowhere
near that level in korean koreans tell
me i speak well but i know myself that
if i listen to any serious material in
korean i lose the thread very quickly
because i simply don't have the words
whereas in
romanian i had the words portuguese and
spanish in fact i had more trouble going
from spanish to portuguese
and the reason was that i went at it the
wrong way we didn't have portuguese at
linc i bought living language i was
trying to learn individual phrases i
bought a book on how you know
differences between spanish and
portuguese i read the book
it doesn't do it you have to basically
let yourself you know be exposed to a
lot of content listening and reading
gradually the brain starts to get used
to it then you start speaking so
i would say that portuguese took me you
know if if i was to be at the level
where i was in romanian after two months
i think it took me six months in
portuguese so
just a brief description description so
how long does it take well it depends on
how similar the language is to a
language you already know
it also depends on how you go at it if
you can afford a teacher one-on-one
uh even one hour a day
and especially if it's three hours a day
you're going to move along a lot more
quickly being in a classroom with 15
other people i don't consider that to be
intensive
uh
so it depends on that how similar they
are and of course what you want to
achieve
if i always strive to achieve some level
of comfortable fluency ability to talk
about you know a variety of things if
you only want to be able to say a few
pleasantries of course that can be
achieved fairly quickly so i kind of
rambled on a bit
uh i don't know if i covered all the
points but how long does it take
a long time
so you better enjoy it
and the more time you put in every day
the fewer number of months it will take
and you need to decide just what it is
you want to achieve in my case i want to
be able to read i want to be able to
read newspapers listen to radio
watch movies so takes a long time i
think i'm in my arabic adventure for a
good two years but i might just mix in a
bit of farsi and turkish just to whet my
appetite for my next adventure so there
you have it thanks for listening bye for
now
[Music]
you